la question qui se pose c'est celle bien
entendu de savoir ce que va apporter la
section de la préservation de
l'environnement de la diversité
biologique et la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique dans l'article 1
de la constitution
alors en fait il ya deux manières
d'appréhender le problème soit de
considérer que c'est une inscription
essentiellement symbolique
c'est à dire que l'inscription à
l'article vise à montrer le poids
accordé aux questions environnementales
au sens large du terme
ça c'est un premier point de vue mais ce
point de vue là n'est pas suffisant il
ne peut être retenue parce que en tout
cas il va falloir et c'est à mon avis un
des points essentiels
il va falloir articuler cette
disposition avec les autres dispositions
constitutionnelles relatives à
l'environnement et je reviendrai sur
cette question mais une question de
cohérence entre différentes normes
constitutionnelles sur le sur la la
question de la portée et du verbe
garantir en fait le terreau garantie on
le trouve déjà dans la constitution
à plusieurs reprises la garantie des
droits de l'homme nécessite une force
politique portes au public
article 12 de la déclaration référence
général à la garantie des droits à
l'article 16 la loi garantit à la femme
des droits égaux à ceux de l'homme prend
rue de 46 la nation garantit un certain
nombre de droits sociaux artisans 11 et
13 du préambule de 1946 en fait on
s'aperçoit que ce terme garantie est
interne qui a déjà fait assez variable
selon le principe auquel se rattache par
exemple la notion de garantie l'europe
peut renvoyer à un droit c'est le cas de
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
ça peut renvoyer aussi un seul objectif
c'est le cas par exemple du droit de
l'as à la santé qui est un objectif
constitutionnel on peut en déduire
théoriquement l'inscription du terme
garanties ne changent pas en lui même la
nature de la protection
constitutionnelle avec cependant deux
bémols le premier tient au fait que son
inscription dans l'article 1
le place à côté est au même niveau des
droits subjectifs égalité devant la loi
respect des croyances et le second ce
qui me semble être une question très
importante plus que celle que j'ai revu
jusqu'à présent c'est que la
conciliation des objectifs
environnementaux socioéconomiques n'est
pas comme dans le cas de l'achat
mentionné ce qui pourrait éventuellement
et la question se posera à conduire le
juge constitutionnel a glissé d'une
conciliation à une hiérarchisation et de
ce point de vue là les travaux
préparatoires ont bien entendu un rôle
important à jouer
le risque enfin qu est que cette
introduction au delà de sa portée
symbolique introduisent un certain
désordre dans le système normatif tente
au regard de sa conciliation avec
certaines dispositions de l'achat que
l'emploi du terme garantis qui peut
renvoyer temps un objectif
constitutionnel qu'à un droit subjectif
et j'ajouterais que la place à l'article
1 est assez redondante avec la référence
faite à l'achat dans le préambule de la
constitution de l'eau sur ce thème
garantie il convient de relever que le
terme garantis pris au sens fort du
terme est inapproprié comment la france
en est elle à elle seule garantir la
préservation de l'environnement et la
diversité biologique
tout au plus peut elle s'engager à
oeuvrer en ce sens de ce point de vue la
référence faite dans le rapport au nom
de la commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale à une quasi obligation de
résultat formule d'ailleurs reprise par
le ministre paraît excessivement
contraignantes voire impossible elle est
non seulement un précise juridiquement
les quasi obligation on a du mal à les
appréhender dans leur réalité et d'autre
part c'est un objectif absolument
impossible il faut plutôt entendre ce
décor faisant peser sur les pouvoirs
publics une obligation d'agir dans le
sens déterminé et probablement avec des
moyens considérée comme efficace
c'est-à-dire comme suscite-t-il d'alain
de 8 poursuit c'était en garantie et non
particulièrement en ligne est l'un des
éléments le deuxième élément que je
voudrais souligner après celui là
cohérence et j'y reviendrai c'est qu'ils
renvoient in fine est aux us
constitutionnel de déterminer la portée
et d'une certaine manière si vous me
permettez cette formule un peu polémique
on pourrait constituer on pourrait
considérer que le constituant même s'il
manière générale ils adoptent des
formules qui peuvent être très l'art se
défaussent pas en quelque sorte sur le
jute
s'agissant du terme lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique lutte au lieu de
garantie j'allais dire on le comprend
bien
on imagine mal que la france puisse
garantir l'absence de dérèglement
climatique alors même que dans une
conception extensive elle peut protéger
sur le sol national
l'environnement et la biodiversité
mais au delà des termes ou ne semble pas
que la portée juridique des termes et
les obligations qu'ils n'engendrent pas
fondamentalement différente préservation
de l'environnement diversité biologique
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
y at il un sens à distinguer ces trois
éléments pour fuir un petit peu le
canevas qui m'avait été transmis le
texte proposé élargissent honda
protection notamment à la lutte contre
le dérèglement climatique
quant à la diversité biologique elles
figurent des oeuvres en bulles de la
charte de l'environnement où le père
biodiversité et je voudrais avoué qu'il
ne relève pas directement compétent de
savoir quelle est la différence entre la
biodiversité la diversité biologique
mais là encore il n'est jamais très sain
qu'un texte constitutionnel en voie de
terre
différents alors même qu'ils pourraient
avoir le même sens
en fait il y a probablement dans la
prise en compte de la diversité
biologique et du changement climatique
une évolution conceptuel le lundi la
diversité biologique et là le changement
climatique ne relève pas directement des
droits de l'homme la start
l'environnement elle avait déjà dans son
préambule cette légère en 1008 et c'est
à dire est ce qu'il s'agit de protéger
l'environnement de l'homme sa santé ses
droits ou est-ce qu'il s'agit finalement
d'une autre protection indépendante de
celle des droits de l'homme dans la
charte les principes énumérés visait
clairement la protection de
l'environnement de l'homme dans son
propre intérêt
ici il y a d'une certaine manière un
certain décanat ce qui est probablement
voulu et assumé
c'est l'ouverture du champ de la
protection à une conception plus vaste
qui il faut le reconnaître peut conduire
à relativiser les droits de l'homme
on peut ainsi imaginer un conflit donc
nécessaire conciliation entre les droits
de l'homme et la protection de la
biodiversité dans des conditions
renouveler et je crois que ça nous sera
assez largement l'équilibré entre les
activités humaines ou l'habitat humain
par exemple et la protection de la faune
ou de la flore on va se trouver là dans
une conciliation qui répondra
probablement à une logique différente de
celle qui a été jusqu'à l'oralité les
effets ces dispositions sur le contrôle
de constitutionnalité des lois et
contrôle de légalité des administrés
en réalité je reviens sur ce point les
faits premier de ce texte est de confier
au juge essentiellement constitutionnel
et administratif
la détermination de la portée des mots
garantie ou lutte
il s'agit donc d'un texte dont la nature
et programmes active mais aussi que le
ce constitutionnel fait produire effet à
toutes les dispositions contenues dans
les textes normatifs quelle que soit la
forme de la rédaction en réalité ce
texte est un texte qui opère j'aimerais
bien un transfert de compétences aux
juges on critique souvent le
renforcement de pouvoirs normatifs du
jute
mais ce renforcement est parfois
l'oeuvre du législateur lui même et il
me semble pour dire les choses de
manière un peu brutale que c'est en
quelque sorte le cas ici ce pouvoir des
juges sera d'ailleurs renforcé par cet
élément de compatibilité entre le texte
a ajouté à l'article 1 de la
constitution et l'article 6 de la charte
qui je rappelle impose une prise en
considération égal de la protection de
l'environnement du développement
économique et progrès social
et là encore c'est un problème de
cohérence qui se posent l'hiérarchie ou
le manque de clarté l'ambiguïté voire
l'absence de cohérence du texte
constitutionnel est à la fois une source
d'insécurité juridique et le transfert
de compétences au profit d'une 6 la
question aura également de savoir si ce
nouveau principe pour interloqué dans le
cas d'une question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité a priori la réponse
devrait être négative car il ne s'agit
pas à proprement parler d'un droit ou
une liberté dans targuer rang peut se
prévaloir mais on peut imaginer que des
associations dont l'objet social
correspond au jeu les garanties
tenteront de son prévaloir dans le cadre
du contrôle a posteriori la noix et la
réponse est encore entre les mains du
luxe si la réponse était affirmative
toute la législation antérieure
alors même qu'elle ré était
constitutionnellement validée par le
conseil constitutionnel pourrait voir sa
constitutionnalité à nouveau examinée au
nom du changement de circonstances
c'est là nous considération qu'il est
nécessaire de prendre alors même qu'elle
pourrait souhaiter ou un sou question
également très importante n'a été posée
celle de l'engagement de la
responsabilité des pouvoirs publics
devant les juridictions françaises
l'utilisation du terme garantis contient
pour le
un défaut d'une obligation de résultat
qui revient n'aurait guère de sens une
obligation d'achat ainsi les pouvoirs
publics pourraient voir leur
responsabilité engagée pour ne pas avoir
employé les moyens nécessaires à cette
fin
cette responsabilité aurait une portée
plus large que celle qui seraient liées
au non-respect du principe de précaution
j'y reviendrai l'obligation de garantie
dont est assortie l'action du
gouvernement comme celle du législateur
pour est incontestablement faciliter
l'engagement de la responsabilité des
pouvoirs publics devant le juge
administratif non seulement du fait des
actes administratifs mais aussi du fait
d'une disposition législative puisque on
sait une récente jurisprudence du
conseil d'état permet d'engager la
responsabilité sans foule du 17 heures
pour non respect d'une disposition
constitution en ce sens la
responsabilité des pouvoirs publics et
renforcer alors même que ne serait pas à
évoquer une atteinte à la santé ou à
l'environnement d'une personne mais
simplement une absence du luth a sorti
un moyen efficace contre la dégradation
de l'environnement de la biodiversité ou
du team hm on voit bien que le champ de
la responsabilité et ex potentiellement
extrêmement large par ailleurs si l'on
retenait une quasi obligation de
résultat pour cette formule
on assisterait un renversement de la
charge de la preuve
il conviendrait alors au pouvoir public
de démontrer qu'aucune mesure n'aurait
pu être prise pour éviter que
l'environnement où la biodiversité ne
soit pas présente sur les obligations et
l'engagement la responsabilité de la
france dans l'ordre international je ne
développerai pas cette question on
attend simplement que le conseil
constitutionnel en a entendu examiner la
constitutionnalité des conventions
internationales que l'enfance entend
ratifier au regard de tels principes
troisième hors de question certaines
dispositions de la charte de
l'environnement de vente elle précisé et
je reviendrai sur le principe de
précaution si on s'attaque à de simples
considérations de légistique à partir du
moment où l'on estime qu'il est un
responsable de promouvoir la place de la
protection de l'environnement la
biodiversité climat dans la constitution
on peut considérer qu'il aurait été
peut-être préférable de modifier la
charte de l'environnement alors que les
droits et devoirs
elle reconnaît sont déjà placés au même
niveau les droits de l'homme et le
principe de souveraineté au rebus de la
constitution on a on a dans la
constitution
cet aspect symbolique où on n'a jamais
dire un système constitutionnel comme le
dit souvent qui repose sur un trépied
dorénavant droits de l'homme
souveraineté protection de
l'environnement il aurait été possible
d'introduire le terme de garanties et
l'élargir le champ de la protection de
la biodiversité au climat
si telle est la volonté politique du
constituante tout en veillant à la
cohérence interne du thème des terres du
texte par une autre solution en vue
d'assurer la cohérence des textes et
afin heureux de rester dans les pures du
projet de loi constitutionnelle aurait
été de rédiger ainsi ce texte
elle garantit la préservation de
l'environnement et de la diversité
biologique
il contredit le mans climatique dont les
conditions prévues par la charte de
l'environnement
quitte à amender si nécessaire cette
dernière on aurait eu ainsi par ce
renvoi est nécessaire cohérence de
l'ensemble des textes
s'agissant du mois celle de précaution
ce principe devait être conçue comme un
principe d'action et nous comme un
principe d'abstention il impose aux
pouvoirs publics comme il a été rappelé
une obligation d'information en amont et
une navigation en aval de tenir compte
des études préalables n'ont pas en
s'abstenant
en cas de risques possibles et non
établies mais en appart en l'important
une réponse proportionnée tenant compte
d'un risque potentiel
édifiant de la boîte de la prévention
d'un risque avéré les jurisprudences
constitutionnelles et administratifs se
sont prononcés pour l'essentiel en ce
sens notamment le conseil d'état se
borne à vérifier si au regard des études
conduites les mesures prises ne sont pas
manifestement insuffisante au regard
maj susceptibles de réalité une
opération c'est d'ailleurs le sens de la
rédaction de l'article 5 de la charte de
vent violent en réalité il me semble que
l'effet pervers du principe de
précaution n'est pas liée au contrôle de
l'activité normative des pouvoirs
publics mais à la mise en jeu de la
responsabilité de l'administration lots
de la responsabilité peint des décideurs
publics en ce sens là les rives et
facilement prévisible qui consiste à
considérer que la réalisation du dommage
permet de caractériser a posteriori une
violation du principe de précaution
en ce sens le principe de précaution
peut devenir un principe incitant à
l'expansion et à paralyser l'action des
pouvoirs publics comme celle des
opérateurs publics par crainte d'une
mise en jeu de la responsabilité
j'allais dire là on a un élément je
crois qu'il faut rattacher probablement
et je permets de probablement de faire
une incidente qui tient au développement
exponentiel de la responsabilité pénale
des responsables politiques et je crois
que l'on a ici au travers du principe de
précaution
un levier pour pour développer cette
responsabilité et je mourrai comme
exemple sans s'emporter bien entendu du
jugement sur ces procédures mais elles
permettent d'illustrer les informations
judiciaires qui ont été conduites au
regard de la politique sanitaire du
gouvernement très récemment et on voit
bien ici une utilisation à mes yeux a
usé du principe de précaution
permettrait un développement exponentiel
de cette responsabilité pénale et donc
probablement qu'une réflexion sur
l'articulation principe de précaution
engagement de responsabilité serait
souhaitable et pourrait conduire à la
rédaction d'un texte probablement de
nature législative
dernière question et j'espère ne pas
être trop long dernière question qui
m'est posée faut-il consacrer le
principe de non régression en matière
environnementale le principe de non
régression et les investissements une
forme édulcorée dans le code de
l'environnement
dans une décision 2020 et 809 dessine
conseil constitutionnel a refusé de
reconnaître valeur constitutionnelle à
ce principe
de mon point de vue non seulement cette
décision est parfaitement justifiée mais
ne pas être particulièrement dangereux
inopportun d'introduire une telle
disposition dans la constitution
de manière générale ce que l'on a appelé
à tort le clic et anti retour est
inapplicable en matière de droits
fondamentaux
en effet le plus souvent les droits
doivent être conciliés pour prendre un
exemple qui n'a rien à voir il faut
concilier la liberté de la presse une
respect de la vie privée et plus vous
renforcer la liberté de la presse plus
vous limitez de respect de la vie privée
un versement en fait de manière générale
le renforcement de la protection d'un
principe affaibli la protection de
l'autre il appartient alors au
législateur d'établir un équilibre et
aux justes de veiller à ce que cet
équilibre ne soit pas manifestement
déséquilibrée établir un principe de
luri recio conduirait d'une part à faire
prévaloir la protection de
l'environnement sur toute autre
considération sur tout autre principe
sur tout autre droit ou liberté et
d'autres pas elle pourrait conduire à
une paralysie de l'action publique qui
dans certaines situations d'urgence peut
être amené à prendre des mesures qui
temporairement une manière limitée porte
atteinte à l'environnement
encore une fois le pouvoir de vue se
trouveraient par ailleurs
considérablement renforcée car il lui
appartiendra de déterminer au cas par
cas si la disposition au reste et
constitue ou non une régression
vous évoquiez l'instant la décision du
conseil constitutionnel de cette année
de la fin de l'année dernière pardon
dans laquelle les le juge ex dit
explicitement ne pas reconnaître le
principe de non régression et dans une
lecture sans doute moins expertes que la
vôtre il m'a semblé percevoir que le
conseil constitutionnel fixé aussi dans
cette même décision
les conditions dans lesquelles ce
ainsi ce ne s'appliquait pas et il ya
quelque chose de paradoxal entre affirmé
ne pas reconnaître un principe et fixer
les conditions dans lesquelles il ne
s'appliquerait pas est-ce que de ce
point de vue là il vous semble qu'on
peut percevoir en creux et contrairement
à l'affirmation pas de principes de non
régression qui a noté néanmoins une
évolution et un nouveau verdissement du
juge constitutionnel
si monsieur baylet peut-être que je vais
donner la parole à d'autres collègues
comme ça vous voyez faire une réponse
globale
monsieur alain marc merci président
merci professeur pour cet exposé très
très clair et très intéressant par
ailleurs nous sommes ici la chambre des
territoires
et c'est vrai que nous avons les hommes
et les autres par exemple je suis
président de la commission des routes du
conseil départemental de l'aveyron et
lorsque nous faisons nous créons nous
souhaitons avoir une voix supplémentaire
bien évidemment nous passionne déjà par
des contraintes qui sont extrêmement
serré au niveau de la dréal etc
si j'ai bien compris votre exposé la
façon que l'on aura d'inscrire ou de
rédiger ce projet de loi
constitutionnelle impactera sur la
volonté de faire ou de ne pas faire des
collectivités et pour et mettant en
cause ultérieurement pénalement les
décideurs paralyser l'action publique et
je crois que c'est sur ce point là qu'il
nous faut être particulièrement vigilant
les uns et les autres si l'on veut dans
un moment après la période qu'ovide où
l'on voudra relancer l'activité par
exemple au niveau des collectivités
locales et bien ce qu'il nous faudrait
faire c'est pouvoir entreprendre des
projets et je crois que il faudrait pas
que la rédaction de ce projet de loi
nous paralyse comme vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure et nous empêche cela parce que
ce serait aussi dommageable pour
l'économie de la france
merci peut-être monsieur le rudulier
sénateur des bouches du rhône exemple de
la commission des lois bien sûr oui
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
professeur
il me semble que en 2000 2002 on s'était
déjà interrogé notamment sur la place de
l'environnement à travers notre
constitution et à travers la commission
copé qui avait émis de mémoire trois
formes proposées trois formes
d'intégration de ce droit à
l'environnement dans notre constitution
et avait rejeté notamment le fait
d'avoir un une déclaration de principe
dans un article même premier auquel on à
dos serait une loi organique pour
préciser justement le contenu de ce
droit à l'environnement
est-ce que vous pouvez nous confirmer
que comme la commission koppens a bel et
bien déjà jugé du fait que la charte de
l'environnement ayant valeur
constitutionnelle et ados c'est donc à
la constitution et est la forme la plus
aboutie en 2002 pour pour son
intégration
merci puis enfin monsieur ministre a
narré charles sénateur du val-d'oise
il est en visio concurrence monsieur les
charges de la parole oui bonjour à tous
rebonjour professeur je voulais
clarifier précisé plus haut le le
l'articulation que vous avez des crises
des critères m'ennuie de façon très très
clairs sur la confrontation entre la
conciliation plutôt entre de droit ou de
l'objectif de valeur constitutionnelle
et les uns et les autres garanties par
soit le le préambule soit par les
principes généraux et je vois dans le
projet de loi sur le climat et
résilience une disposition qui va
introduire un freinage très substantiel
appliqué jusque dans les programmes les
plans locaux d'urbanisme de chaque
commune sur la l'artificialisation des
sols l'utilisation de sol
aujourd'hui et naturels ou ou agricoles
dans un gîte urbain ces 10
aujourd'hui consiste à diviser par deux
ans nombre d'hectares au nombre de
kilomètres carrés le chiffre de
l'artificialisation constaté sur une
certaine période intérieur est-ce que
roux titre de la garantie de la
biodiversité point sur lequel d'ailleurs
il peut y avoir débat parce que la
biodiversité par construction est
elle-même évolutive aircap de diversité
d'aujourd'hui n'est pas celle qui a dix
mille ans est ce que au titre de cette
notion de garantie ça aboutirait à dire
que une disposition comme cela qu'il ne
fait que limiter la consommation
consommation de sol naturel ne serait
pas conforme à l'objectif de garantie et
qu'on devrait directement passer à 0
merci monsieur le ministre
et puis notre rapporteur monsieur
guillaume chevrollier sénateur de la
mayenne
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le professeur pour votre exposé
extrêmement clair où vous avez dû suivre
les différents projets de révision
constitutionnelle en ayant en 2018 et
avait eu différentes propositions de
verbes dans la modification il ya eu un
agir pour favoriser maintenant garantir
ce que vous pouvez faire une comparaison
de ce glissement sémantique et avec
votre analyse bien sûr et deuxième
question en réaction d'ailleurs à
l'intervention à l'instant du château
richer sur l'état de l'environnement la
préservation de la biodiversité
on sait on parle beaucoup aussi de
renaturation et après c'est quelle
référence à quelle époque fait référence
su pour revenir à un état naturel c'est
qu'il peut être très très subjectif et
qui peut lui aussi être source de
beaucoup d'interprétations et de
contentieux et du discussions et créent
une instabilité juridique qui est posé
les problèmes économiques
merci merci
ce professeur vous allez on vous laisse
la parole merci beaucoup surpris d'un
côté je vais essayer de répondre autant
que puisse se faire à l'ensemble de ces
questions sur sur la première question
sur le principe de velours épais de non
régression
en fait je crois que le le le conseil
constitutionnel à une jurisprudence qui
est extrêmement classique on ne peut pas
considérer qu'un droit ne peut jamais
être être remis en cause tout simplement
dans une question d équilibre entre les
droits mais ce que dit et aux avez
raison de le souligner ce que dit le
conseil constitutionnel c'est que les
les
l'évolution législative ne doit pas
priver de garantie légale
l'ensemble des principes qui figure dans
l'achat est en fait d'une certaine
manière le le conseil constitutionnel
fait masse des exigences
constitutionnelles figurant dans la dans
la charte de l'environnement qui indique
qu' on ne peut pas priver garanties
légales c'est-à-dire qu'il n'ya pas un
principe de non régression mais qu'il y
à un principe selon laquelle on ne peut
pas effacer mécanismes de protection là
là j'allais dire que le là c'est pas un
système de cliquet anti-retour mais
c'est un système de seuil des cent en
dessous d'un certain seuil quand je
conduirai à priver de 46 les gains des
exigences constitutionnelles
donc on a ici un mécanisme qui protège
réellement les principes
j'allais dire de toute intervention
législative qui irait trop loin dans la
régression les lire on en n'a pas on n'a
pas été encore une fois on n'a pas à
cliquer mais on peut avoir un plancher
en dessous duquel on ne peut pas
descendre sur sur l'âge je réponde à la
question sur la paralysie en même temps
qu'eux
c'est la question posée par le ministre
alain richard
je vais bien entendu pas répondre à ces
questions est d'autant plus que
imaginons qu'un jour comme vul
administratives qu'ils soient confrontés
je ne peux pas de lettre réponse avant
sans lui je ne renie pas mais je crois
qu'il ya quand même quelque chose qui
est important c'est que là est ce que la
vraie question c'est est-ce que lauro ou
pas avec la formule de l'article 6 de la
charge dans laquelle le développement
durable c'est l'environnement le
développement économique et le progrès
social
pour moi la question fondamentale elle
est là si on reste dans les pures la
guerre il n'y a pas véritablement le
problème sera dans l'ain du risque ou
danse classique et on verra on vérifiera
que l'autorité administrative à
équilibrer ces trois éléments là et que
cas par cas pas un déséquilibre
manifeste
si on raisonne autrement ses horizons
autrement et qu'on considère en effet
comme le dit le ministre de la justice
qui a une quasi obligation de résultat
la situation est tout à fait différente
et je ne sais pas quelles réponses
devront être apportées mais ce dont je
suis absolument certain c'est que l'on
va générer par là l otan cieux considéra
il est bien évident que la création du
rond point
il est bien évident que
l'artificialisation partielle des pères
pourra faire l'objet d'un contentieux en
disant justement qu'il n'y a pas
véritablement ou garantie de la
biodiversité ou dut ou du climat et gers
le cheveu ce monde de ce manque de
cohérence entre la formule de la
constitution qui sera ajouté à la
constitution et la formulation de
l'article 6 de l'achat et
pardonnez-moi jade expression triviale
mais c'est un nid à contentieux
cette année un contentieux et c'est
d'autant plus un nid un contentieux que
finalement on rentre pour reprendre
l'exemple du de l'artificialisation des
sols on rentre dans ce que je disais
tout à l'heure
est ce que la question va véritablement
je pose est est-ce que la protection de
la biodiversité doit l'emporter sur le
développement de l'habitat est ce qu'il
s'agit finalement de créer un équilibre
entre les deux ou est ce qu'il s'agit de
faire prévaloir n'a sur l'eau les singes
et une question qu'il faut se poser mais
j'allais dire le seul le problème de mon
point de vue c'est que si cette question
n'est pas traitée elle est renvoyée au
jus est ce qu'en fera le juge
constitutionnel notamment aux usa miss
pratique on peut pas véritablement le
dire à la vente mais qu'on sait qu'il y
aura des ddd des problèmes sur sur la
commission coppens et la la la place de
la plage de la référence à
l'environnement dans la constitution
comme je disais tout à l'heure
cette place elle et elle est éminente
puisque lé dans la charte de
l'environnement
il n'y a pas que la charte de
l'environnement il y à la référence des
droits et les devoirs définis dans la
charte de l'environnement dans le
préambule de la constitution et prend
aux nues de la confiture sert de
préambule de la constitution et
l'article 20 ils ont d'une certaine
manière le même objet on peut considérer
que l'article 1er prolonge le prao rue
de la constitution et la récurrence
n'est pas forcément indispensable
enfin les termes agir favoriser garantir
d'un oui dans agir
il ya une obligation d'action d'en
favoriser le problème se pose de l'
équilibre mais c'est pas nécessairement
une obligation qui va prévaloir sur
toutes les autres dans la terme de
anti si on retient cette quasi cette
quasi obligation de résultat qui encore
une fois non seulement me semble
dangereuse mais me semble en plus
totalement il réalise
franchement je ne vois pas comment seul
le législateur ou gouvernement français
vont pouvoir maintenir la biodiversité
c'est qu'on aurait envoyé le terme
participent à la garantie 2 ce qui
aurait été encore une autre solution
participe à la garantie 2 on aurait eu
je crois un résultat qui aurait été
probablement tout aussi satisfaisant sur
le plan des principes et peut-être
beaucoup plus réaliste la france
participe à la garantie est à la lutte
je crois que là on aurait eu au moins un
texte qui aurait répondu encore une fois
principe de rennes je dirais que d'un
point de vue juridique
d'un point de vue juridique du point de
vue constitutionnel
cette révision de la constitution est
inutile juridiquement elle est inutile
juridiquement quelle que soit la
formulation je pense qu'on y reviendra
la france ali favorise garantie protège
préserve quel que soit le le verbe
utilisé mon analyse me conduit à dire
que le l'inscription à l'article 1er de
la constitution de du respect de la
biodiversité de la protection de
l'environnement et de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et
juridiquement inutile politiquement
symboliquement peut être utile mais sur
le plan juridique et vous poser cette
question en tant que juriste et les de
mon point de vue inutile pourquoi
inutile parce que
la préservation de la biodiversité la
protection de l'environnement et la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
ont déjà valeur constitutionnelle valeur
constitutionnelle c'est à dire ont déjà
une valeur supérieure à la loi qui
oblige le législateur le gouvernement
les autorités publiques qui oblige le
tout les pouvoirs publics constitués à
respecter les principes les principes de
respect de l'environnement de la
biodiversité et de l'action contre le
réchauffement climatique et ses
principes vous le savez évidemment comme
moi ils sont inscrits dans la charte de
l'environnement et cette charte de
l'environnement
elle est adossée à la constitution et
par l'action du conseil constitutionnel
elle a la même valeur que les articles
de la constitution
on peut faire une comparaison avec la
déclaration des droits de l'homme de
1789 la déclaration de 17 ans gars 9
elle est adossée à la constitution elle
n'est pas dans la constitution
même chose pour le préambule de 1946 et
bien c'est le conseil constitutionnel
qui dans une décision de juillet 1971 à
intégrer la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et le préambule de 1946 à
l'intérieur de la constitution et le
conseil constitutionnel a fait la même
chose avec la charte de l'environnement
qui a dont déjà valeur constitutionnelle
c'est à dire une vidéo d'abord au
supérieur encore une fois à à la loi et
j'ajoute que si on si on se rappelle le
contexte et je répands une à une
question que kim hakim avait été posée
sur
est ce que est ce qu'il faudrait pas
rajouter la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
mais si on se souvient du contexte dans
lequel la charte de l'environnement a
été conçu pensez vous lui rédiger cette
suite à la lame à la fameuse phrase du
président chirac
notre maison brûle et on regarde
ailleurs autrement dit la charte de
l'environnement a été élaborée pensée
précisément dans le but de lutter contre
le réchauffement climatique il ya donc
tout dans cette dans cette charte de
l'environnement qui constitue le cadre
constitutionnel à l'intérieur duquel les
pouvoirs publics législateur pouvait
réglementaire et même comment dire les
acteurs les acteurs sociaux 1 doivent
définir leur leur politique je
reviendrai sur acteurs sociaux d'un d'un
dans un instant donc si vous voulez le
le tout est déjà là
sur le plan juridique j'ajoute que
l'arctique de la révision de 2008 initié
par le président sarkozy a ajouté à
l'article 34 1 alinéa disons que le
législateur détermine les principes
fondamentaux de de la lutte contre
contre le réchauffement climatique la
protection de l'environnement quand il
appartient au législateur de déterminer
les principes fondamentaux de la
protection de l'environnement dans le
cadre constitutionnel défini par par la
charte de l'environnement
donc ça ne servirait à rien ça ne
servirait à rien si vous laissez comme
les propositions que l'on voit fleurir
sur il faudrait inscrire la laïcité à
l'article 1er de la constitution mais ça
servirait à rien puisque leur pays
premier dit déjà que la france est une
république démocratique laïque sociale
etc
alors non seulement ça se servirait à
rien parce que c'est déjà écrit mais les
juges ont déjà utilisé cette charte de
l'environnement et il ya trois grandes
décisions du conseil constitutionnel qui
ont été rendus pendant l'année qui vient
il ya la décision du 31 janvier 2001 du
10 décembre 2020 dont vous me parlez
dans les questionnaires et récemment la
décision du 19 mars 2020 théâtre et ses
trois décisions montrent que le conseil
constitutionnel utilisent déjà les
principes constitutionnels pour
apprécier le contenu des politiques
publiques ou des lois défini par le
législateur
je voudrais revenir un instant sur la
décision du 31 janvier de 2020 le le
parlement vous aviez voté des élus de la
nation avait voté une loi interdisant la
production l'importation et la
commercialisation de produits
phytopharmaceutiques et les sociétés des
entreprises concernées par ce secteur
avait fait un recours devant le conseil
constitutionnel par la voix de la qpc je
passe les détails au motif que c'est que
cette loi porte atteinte à la liberté
d'entreprendre
que dit le conseil constitutionnel le
conseil constitutionnel dit oui en effet
en effet cette loi porte atteinte à la
liberté d'entreprendre puisque ça
interdit aux entreprises d'importer de
produire et de commercialiser
oui mais dit le conseil cette atteinte à
la liberté d'entreprendre est justifiée
par un objectif de valeur
constitutionnelle
inscrit dans la charte de
l'environnement qui est de protéger
protéger la biodiversité lutter contre
le réchauffement climatique et préserver
la vie la biodiversité
autrement dit
le conseil constitutionnel a déjà
utilisé le principe de la protection de
l'environnement de la biodiversité pour
faire céder à un autre principe qui est
la liberté la liberté d'entreprise et
c'est le travail
je dirais quotidien du juge
constitutionnel comme de tout juge il
s'agit d'arbitrer entre différents
droits qu'elle la liberté d'entreprendre
est un droit constitutionnel
la protection de l'environnement et de
la biodiversité est un droit
constitutionnel et le rôle du juge
constitutionnel est de vérifier que
l'arbitrage que la conciliation entre
les deux est raisonnable et
proportionnée nécessaires adéquates et
en l'espèce le conseil constitutionnel a
jugé que bien sûr il y avait une
atteinte à la liberté d'entreprendre
mais cette atteinte n'était pas
disproportionnée et qu'elles étaient
justifiées par la nécessité de respecter
l'objectif de valeur constitutionnelle
inscrit dans la charte donc m m maître
d'un article 1er le fait que dalle à la
république garantie de la protection de
l'environnement ne changerait rien le
conseil a déjà utilisé cette ce principe
pour faire céder la liberté
d'entreprendre il ya une autre décision
qu'est la décision du 10 décembre 2000
le tient du 10 décembre 2020 ou là le il
s'agissait de de savoir si la halle
autorisation dérogatoire de de
pesticides étaient conformes aux enfers
respecter leur environnement est là
encore que dit le conseil le conseil
libon réintroduire vous permettre vous
permettre exceptionnellement le
l' usage de pesticides porte atteinte à
la biodiversité ya un risque pour les
insectes
il ya un risque pour la qualité de l'eau
mais ni le conseil
le législateur a posé un certain nombre
de garanties qui conduisent à penser dit
le conseil qui conduisent à penser que
finalement cette atteinte à la
biodiversité est limité et par
conséquent la loi qui autorise de
manière dérogatoire la réutilisation en
deux pesticides n'est pas manifestement
contraires au respect de la bio de la
biodiversité dont on à la décision du 31
janvier et on à la décision du dessin
qui montre le que le conseil fait un
usage équilibré alors on peut toujours
discuter ce que est ce que est ce que
l'équilibré est raisonnable et juste
assez de travail des commentateurs de
dire le conseil a exagéré ou le conseil
s'est trompé mais si on regarde les
choses de manière comment dire la plus
neutre possible
on voit bien que le conseil
constitutionnel de la décision du 10
décembre
énumère très longuement les garanties
qui figure dans la loi pour dire au
regard des garanties eh bien je
considère que la réintroduction des
pesticides ne porte pas atteinte à
l'environnement
s'il n'y avait pas eu ces garanties
alors je vous connaissez aussi bien ces
garanties que moi donc je ne les énumère
pas s'il n'y avait pas ces garanties
peut-être que le conseil constitutionnel
avait censuré et donc on va nyala le
fait que le vix slater a intégré en
quelque sorte en amont l'exigence
constitutionnelle puisque il a assorti
l'autorisation dérogatoire d'utiliser
des pesticides de 2,2 de garantie qui
permette de préserver le
l'environnement la dernière décision est
temps que celle du 19 mars 2021 alors
est elle est très intéressant cette
décision parce que il s'agit des charte
rédigée au niveau départemental pour
fixer la limite à partir desquels on ne
peut pas faire d'épandage de pesticides
et donc ces chartes et sont élaborées au
niveau départemental ce sont des charges
donc c'est pas des lois en ce sont des
chats et l centaine élaboré au niveau
départemental approuvé par le préfet et
ses chartes
c'est pour ça tout à l'heure que je
disais que les cadres constitutionnels
s'appliquer aux acteurs sociaux c'est
ses chats approuvé par le préfet sont
des décisions publiques qui peuvent être
contestés devant le conseil
constitutionnel et le conseil
constitutionnel a considéré que ces
chartes devait être élaboré non pas
seulement avec les représentants des
habitants de la zone concernée
mais comme le dit la charte de
l'environnement que toute personne c'est
laisser le mot de ce qui figure dans la
charte que toute personne ne devait
pouvoir participer à l'élaboration de
ces chartes et le conseil
constitutionnel a censuré cette
disposition législative au motif que les
sharks en question ne devait pas
simplement est élaborée entre les
représentants des habitants et le
l'autorité préfectorale n'est que devait
participer à l'élaboration de cette
charte
toute personne total le conseil
constitutionnel donne son plein effet à
à l'expression de de la charte encore
une fois le conseil prend au mot la
charte dite toute personne doit
participer a le droit de participer à la
protection de l'environnement le conseil
dit toute personne c'est pas les
représentants des personnes c'est toute
personne et le conseil avant que a donc
censuré
autrement dit le seul e la charte de
l'environnement constitue déjà un cadre
pour la détermination de toutes les
politiques publiques que ce soit au
niveau national ou au niveau donc au
niveau départemental le conseil
constitutionnel vous le savez ne
contrôle pas les lois par rapport aux
conventions internationales mais
simplement regard de la constitution et
le contrôle du respect par les autorités
françaises des conventions
internationales
là encore elle existe déjà et il ya
encore des exemples récents avec ce
qu'on appelle la sphère du siècle le le
juge administratif a condamné l'état au
motif que l'état n'avait pas pris des
n'est pas défini des politiques
publiques permettant de réduire la
production de co2 et n'avait pas
respecté la trajectoire définie par
l'accord de paris donc déjà vous voyez
sens que j'ai besoin de réformer c'est
cet article 1er de la constitution
déjà les conventions internationales
sont utilisés notamment par le juge
administratif pour condamner l'état dans
son inaction dans son inaction politique
dans vos questionnaires aussi vous me
posez la question la question des du
vocabulaire vous me dîtes si je suis
trop trop long
la question du vocabulaire en favorise
garantie aj lutte j'ai je veux dire que
je suis assez réservé sur eux
l'importance que l'on donne la portable
ou l'importance normative que l'on prête
à à chacun de ces de ces verbes garantie
favoriser agit sur le plan sur le plan
sur le plan du défi regarder évidemment
sur le dictionnaire et quand vous allez
à garantie garantir le synonyme
favorisés quand vous allez à favoriser
il ya garantir donc je voulais déjà au
niveau simplement comment dire et
sémantique les verts de ce renvoi se
renvoient les uns les autres il ya
favorisé ses protégés garantir ses
protégés bon bref c'est sévère de ce
fonds ico les uns les autres sans qu'on
puisse me semble-t-il en déduire une
différence de d'impact de et de portée
normative
il avait le même débat il a vu le même
débat lors de la révision
constitutionnelle de 1906 à 1999 sur
l'égal accès des femmes aux mandats
publics et il y avait déjà eu une
discussion s il faut mettre favoriser ou
est-ce qu'il faut mettre garantir et
finalement l'accord cet effet sur
favorise et on avait dix ans favorise la
loi devra favoriser l'égal accès des
femmes mais dans le préambule de 1946
qui a valeur constitutionnelle
l'article 1er
ni la nation je sais pas si c'est
exactement la nation mais l'article le
premier dit la loi garantit à la femme
des droits égaux à ceux de l'homme
autrement dit vous voyez de la loi
garantit dit le préambule de 1946 et en
1999 on met la loi favorise l'égal accès
des femmes aux mandats publics
est-ce que favoriser moins fortes
garanties sur le plan normatif le
conseil constitutionnel ne n'accorde pas
n'accorde pas cette comment dire cette
différence normative que con con que le
discours que j'entends actuellement lui
il lui prête
quand on dit on dirait on dit souvent
que favorise serait moins contraignant
que garantit non sur le plan sur le plan
juridique le conseil constitutionnel
n'attache pas au mot favoriser un pacte
contraignant moindres comme aux
garanties
la preuve en est dans la jurisprudence
concernant les l'égal accès des femmes
que le légiste est que les concitoyens
dit garantie en 1946 ou favorise en 1999
le conseil constitutionnel protège de la
même manière l'égalité entre les hommes
et les femmes et s'en sert de la même
manière pour équilibrer un droit avec
les autres le principe de non régression
il n'est pas formulée l'an encore
favoriser garantie agi protège améliore
le mot principe de non régression ne
figure pas dans la jurisprudence du but
du conseil constitutionnel le mot
l'expression mais l'a choisi et si j'ose
dire un sérieux
conseil laisse le législateur et encore
heureux le conseil laisse le législateur
modifié après abroger et remplacer des
dispositions par par d'autres
dispositions
ce que fait le conseil ils vérifient que
les dispositions nouvelles introduites
par le législateur encore une fois je
side ne saurait priver de garanties
légales le droit de vivre dans un
environnement équilibré et respectueux
de la santé publique consacrée par
l'article 1er donc le principe de non
régression il est là déjà la chose hélas
si le si le mot si le mot ni n'y est pas
donc ce sont toutes ces raisons qui me
conduise à penser que cette cette
révision de la constitution serait
serait inutile en remarquant d'ailleurs
que cette révision de la constitution ne
vient pas de la convention pour le
climat à l'origine de cette de cette
proposition de révision
constitutionnelle s'est pas lassé par la
convention qui l'a proposé
c'est le présent mais république qui
dans son propre rôle dans la proposition
de révision de la constitution de 2018
je crois avait déjà prévu de
d'introduire cette disposition dans
l'entente l'article premier j'avais
d'ailleurs déjà à l'époque considéré que
c'était juridiquement inutile et je
continue donc à la considérer
juridiquement encore une fois puisque
c'était sur ce point que vous
m'interrogez totalement inutile merci
monsieur le président merci aussi aux
professeurs vont être exposés très clair
sur l'inutilité de cette révision
constitutionnelle si elle est inutile
est ce que pour autant elle n'a aucune
conséquence et notamment des
conséquences négatives sur une vie d'ici
réalisations de la société et entravé
des activités économiques notamment
et une deuxième question la charte de
l'environnement donc date de 2004 et les
décisions du conseil constitutionnel
faisant état de la charte
là vous en avez cité 3 qui date de 2020
ok c'est à dire que pendant quinze ans
elle n'a pas été source d'inspiration
pour le juge constitutionnel et on voit
des décisions en 2020 hors des projets
vous l'avez évoqué de révision de la
constitution date de 2018
s'il n'y a pas un télescopage qui
explique que voilà il ya une volonté de
d'introduire des dispositions dans la
constitution pour vraiment qu' une
valeur constitutionnelle puisque le
jugement soit n'était pas saisie avant
2020 dans le texte qui nous est proposé
il ya une partie qui ne pose pas de
problèmes pour réussir à rechercher une
conciliation entre les droits et il ya
une partie qui pose problème
la partie qui ne pose pas de problème
c'est celle pour laquelle on a introduit
cette révision constitutionnelle c'est à
dire le climat parce que alors là le
climat
c'est très sympathiquement écrit la
république lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique alors lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique évidemment ça ne
vous oblige en réalité à rien on
pourrait même prévoir que si on lutte
comme la chèvre de monsieur seguin
contre le dérèglement climatique que à
la fin de la nuit
le loup nous à manger on a fait notre
devoir et le conseil constitutionnel ne
pourra rien trouvé à y redire
le seul avantage éventuelle de cette
disposition c'est que le dérèglement
climatique n'est pas mentionnée comme
tel dans la charte de l'environnement
et si un jour nous sommes gouvernés par
un bol sonar haut il ne pourra pas dire
le dérèglement climatique je m'en fiche
parce que il ya un objectif de valeur
constitutionnelle qui sera inscrit dans
la constitution et le dérèglement
climatique aura donc une certaine
importance dans notre ordre juridique
l'autre partie de la phrase on veut
introduire et là je je je me sépare pour
le moment mais vous allez peut-être me
convaincre finalement 2
de votre analyse c'est la garantie de la
préservation de l'environnement et de la
biodiversité
je voudrais tout d'abord dire que
l'exemple que vous avez cités sur
l'égalité des droits entre hommes et
femmes ne m'a pas convaincu car si le
préambule prévoit cette égalité de droit
elle impliquait normalement que le
législateur n'avait pas le droit de
favoriser les femmes en faisant la
parité aux élections et c'est d'ailleurs
la raison même pour laquelle il a fallu
inscrire dans la constitution que la loi
peut favoriser l'égalité enfin l'égal
accès des femmes et des hommes puisque
les droits des femmes et des hommes
doivent être égaux normalement et dans
cette réforme de la parité il a fallu
donner plus de droits aux femmes qu'aux
hommes
pour s'assurer qu'elle serait qu elle
accéderait à des fonctions dont elle
était en raison de l'état de la société
en quelque sorte privé donc je laisse de
côté cette illustration mais peut-être
en avez vous d'autres qui tendrait à
réduire à néant la différence entre
favoriser et garantir moi je crois qu'il
ya quand même une différence importante
entre favoriser et garantir et quand je
me reporte à la charte de
l'environnement je vois bien qu'il est
écrit que toute personne a le devoir de
prendre part à la préservation et à
l'amélioration de l'environnement je
vous ai bien entendu le conseil
constitutionnel a inclus dans toute
personne le législateur comme toute
autorité publique et donc nous avons le
devoir de prendre part à la préservation
et à l'amélioration de l'environnement
mais prendre part ça ne nous oblige à
pas grand chose
nous pouvons prendre part inefficacement
mais nous aurons pris part ça c'est une
obligation qui est faible et quand on se
reportent ensuite à l'article 6 de la
même charte de l'environnement
on y lit plus précisément des politiques
publiques doivent promouvoir un
développement durable et là c'est très
intéressant parce que la charte à un
esprit d'équilibré
elle explique ce que c'est que de
promouvoir le développement durable en
disant que les politiques publiques
doivent je la cite
s'il y est la protection et la mise en
valeur de l'environnement le
développement économique et le progrès
social et là on voit bien que il n'ya
pas de droit absolu on est bien dans la
logique intellectuelle de la déclaration
des droits de l'homme et des citoyens
qui ne proclame aucun droit sans
aussitôt posé les limites de ses droits
c'est à dire d'autres droits ou l'ordre
public qui est définie par la loi
l'article 6 de la charte de
l'environnement reste dans un monde
connu mais la garantie de la
préservation non pas de la protection
d'ailleurs mais de la préservation de
l'environnement et de la biodiversité
on peut quand même lui donner un autre
sens c'est à dire que là c'est un absolu
si vous devez garantir vous ne pouvez
tolérer la moindre atteinte à la
préservation de l'environnement et la
moindre atteinte à la biodiversité donc
je voulais relancer notre discussion en
vous faisant part de ses arguments et
j'espère que vous les tiendrait en échec
ça m'arrangerait que c'est réussi
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
professeur vers parole oui merci
monsieur le président loin de deux mois
le l'idée de de convaincre le monsieur
le ministre
bah je je je connais sa rhétorique et je
ne prétends pas renverser le l'analyse
qui viennent de de te produire si je
regarde la question qui est posée sur
finalement garantir et et favoriser et
si si on essaie de donner aux au verbe
comment dire une une portée normative
différente d'un teint d'intensité
normative d'intensité normative
différentes
les verts qui sont employés dans la
charte de l'environnement
je dirais sont plus exigeants que le mot
garantie ou le mot favorisent ou le mot
agit vous les avez cité les verbes s'est
améliorée promouvoir et promouvoir
vous avez cité l'article 6 en conciliant
avec le développement économique et le
progrès social c'est exactement ce qu'a
fait le conseil constitutionnel jusqu'à
présent c'est exactement ce qu'a fait le
conseil constitutionnel jusqu'à présent
et je réponds à la première question je
n'hésitais que les dernières décisions
mais le conseil constitutionnel dès 2006
2007 a donné valeur constitutionnelle à
chacun des articles de la charte de
l'environnement
alors après ça dépend des saisines la
qpc est en vigueur que depuis 2000 2010
dont le faible nombre de décisions du
conseil constitutionnel relative au
droit de l'environnement tient au fait
que le conseil n'était n'était pas
saisie
mais dès 2006 dès 2007 il y a eu des
décisions du conseil qui encore une fois
ont accordé valeur constitutionnelle
puisque la grande question c'était ça
est ce que le fait est ce que la spière
de l'homme de l'environnement c'était
simplement un guide de même que certains
considéraient pendant très longtemps que
la déclaration des droits de l'homme
n'était pas du droit mais de la
philosophie de la morale
ah bon est ce que la charte de
l'environnement c'était un guide
voilà ça serait bien si vous bien est-ce
que l'achat d'un lot de l'environnement
oz et obligation de faire
donc est-ce que c'était du droit bon là
la question a pu est débattue dès 2006
le conseil constitutionnel a dit
du doigt ce sont des principes
juridiques au même titre que les autres
principes et qui oblige les les pouvoirs
publics donc le le le verbe utilisé dans
la charte de l'environnement ont
potentiellement une intensité normative
plus forte que garantir et favoriser et
pourtant et pourtant le conseil
constitutionnel a admis en le 10
décembre 2020 que l'on pouvait
réintroduire les pesticides de manière
dérogatoire parce qu'il y avait un
certain nombre de garanties donc la
conciliation a bien été a bien été fait
est ce que le conseil y en aurait rendu
une décision différente si le verbe
avait été garanti
je ne crois pas je ne crois pas le le le
le conseil aurait très bien pu s'appuyer
sur le verbe promouvoir et améliorer
pour dire que même de manière
dérogatoire la réintroduction des
pesticides ne permettait pas d'améliorer
la préservation de 2
l'amélioration de l'environnement
puisque pendant trois ans à aller au
contraire la la la la faire souffrir
bon donc même avec des verbes fort comme
promouvoir le conseil constitutionnel a
accepté que de manière dérogatoire en
pis réintroduire les pesticides
donc je comprends le jeu comprend je
dirais le débat politique sur favoriser
garantir etc
je ne pense pas que et je sais que le
jeu ministre bae et juristes et sait
très bien comment fonctionne le lait les
juges
je pense que les le comment dire les
mots les verbes sont comment dire
soumise à une interprétation il est
toujours contextuelle et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui les dernières décisions
du conseil constitutionnel montre que ce
qui importe au conseil constitutionnel
c'est que les politiques publiques
protège la biodiversité et
l'environnement
ce nouveau projet il apporte quelque
chose au moins sur le plan symbolique
juridiquement c'est beaucoup plus
incertain et j'y reviendrai évidemment
par ailleurs je pense qu'il faut faire
preuve d' extrêmement d'humilité par
rapport aux questions que vous m'avez au
soumises
c'est à dire alors j'ai évidemment je
suis allé voir la vie qu'a rendu le
conseil d'état sur ce projet de révision
moi je trouve qu'il faut être très
prudent sur la manière dont il faut
interpréter les termes parce que tout
dépend de la façon dont les requérants
vont s'emparer éventuellement de ce
nouvel article 1 et surtout dans le juge
va s'en emparer il ne faut jamais
oublier qu'il ya une grande marge
d'appréciation quand même du fus gens à
l'égard des dispositions
constitutionnelles on l'a évidemment je
fais allusion au juge constitutionnel et
donc je crois que sur les potentialités
contenues dans ce projet de révision il
convient d'être extrêmement
prudent et de ne pas faire de réponse
trop tranchées d'autres difficultés
d'ailleurs surgissent à titre préalable
c'est aussi donc qui va s'emparer du
texte ça je l' ai déjà dit mais comment
articuler si le projet de révision
constitutionnelle devait aboutir comment
articuler cet article 1 avec la charte
de l'environnement
comment le juge va devoir au combiné
l'interprétation de ces deux textes pour
moi beaucoup d'incertitudes demeurent à
cet égard vous aviez soumis à comme
première question à mon analyse à la
lumière donc en effet des travaux qui
avaient conduit notamment le cri d'eau
mais pas seulement sur l'observatoire
l'obligeant sur la qpc en matière
d'environnement
vous me posiez la question de savoir
s'il était nécessaire de renforcer les
exigences constitutionnelles liées à la
protection d'environnement et si oui
comment
donc à mon sens il est nécessaire de
renforcer les exigences liées à la
protection d'environnement ça ne fait
aucun doute dans mon esprit
et d'ailleurs quand nous avions soumis
le notre travail 1 au conseil
constitutionnel mais je précise que ce
travail était rendu en 2019 a été
effectuée par don en 2019
ce qui est très important et rendu tout
début 2020 nous avions invité le conseil
constitutionnel a plus alors je vais
essayer de résumer mais peut-être à plus
d'audace dans l'interprétation du de la
charte de l'environnement à on avait
surtout on considérait que le problème
n'était pas dans la charte et dans la
constitution mais le problème était
surtout ce que le juge faisait de la
charte de l'environnement ont considéré
par exemple que le conseil
constitutionnel pouvait aller plus loin
en en combinant l'interprétation des
différentes normes c'est à dire en
s'appuyant à la fois sur la déclaration
des droits de l'homme de 1789 sur la
charte de l'environnement sur le
préambule de 46 ce qu'il ne fait pas
coût ce qui ne faisait pas beaucoup en
tout état de cause
et puis on l'a vite et aussi à s'appuyer
sur le préambule de la charte de
l'environnement qui contient des
dispositions intéressantes et notamment
sur la conservation de la diversité
biologique
il reviendrait également mais alors là
c'est mon point de vue personnel il se
trouve que depuis la restitution du
rapport à la jurisprudence du conseil
constitutionnel me semble avoir évolué
plutôt dans un sens favorable
alors il faut nuancer mais je vais dire
dans un sens favorable à la protection
de l'environnement même s'il faut
nuancer
alors j'ai fait évidemment allusion à la
décision qu'il a rendue juste après la
restitution de notre de notre rapport
sur le fait que en interprétant
notamment s'appuyant sur le transit de
la charte de l'environnement
le juge a considéré que la protection
d'environnement constituer un nouvel
objectif de valeur constitutionnelle ce
qui veut bien dire qu'il pouvait aller
plus loin dans l'interprétation du texte
et il me semble que c'est une
jurisprudence qui va qui va dans le bon
sens et puis plus récemment dans une
autre décide en 2020 que vous aviez
d'ailleurs mentionné dans le dans le
questionnaire le conseil constitutionnel
en se fondant sur l'article 2 de la
charte de l'environnement a affirmé que
le législateur ne saurait priver de
garanties légales le droit à
l'environnement consacré à l'article
donc l'interprétation du juge sur la
charte de l'environnement elles évoluent
elles évolué a évolué afin dans un sens
que je trouve plutôt favorable ça ne
veut pas dire toujours
évidemment que ce n'est pas parce que
l'interprétation du juge évolué que ces
décisions vont tous dans le sens de la
protection d'environnement mais en tout
cas ils opèrent un contrôle que je
trouve au fath qui a évolué
favorablement
donc je
j'étais évidemment un peu embarrassé
c'est à dire comment peut-on défendre le
projet de révision parce que au fond
faut quand même essayer de canton des
juristes on essaye de trouver des
arguments pour des arguments contre donc
quelles seraient les arguments
éventuellement pour défendre un tel
projet de révision même si je répète
vraiment j'insiste pour moi le
renforcement des exigences de la
protection d'environnement ne passe pas
nécessairement par une révision du texte
constitutionnel pourriez madame notre
aucun argument en faveur n'est pas
forcément la bonne
non mais j'en ai quand même essayer
c'est pas c'est pas tellement la pureté
de la discussion
c'est pas je vais essayer à tout prix de
trouver des arguments enfin je dis ça ne
semblerait pas de sens mais est ce que
le texte apporte quelque chose qu est-ce
qui est éventuellement intéressant mais
vous allez voir que finalement c'est
c'est assez limité
on pourrait dire que le contexte en fait
dadaux de l'environnement enfin depuis
que la commission copas avait réfléchi à
la charte de l'environnement
finalement le contexte a évolué et que
la crise climatique s'est accentuée que
les contentieux climatique se
multiplient bon on pourrait en parler
d'ailleurs et que les maisons j'ai aussi
liée à la diversité biologique se sont
enfin voila se sont aggravées
donc de ce point de vue là la révision
constitutionnelle aurait au moins à
l'effet symbolique d'inscrire à
l'article 1er à côté des valeurs
vraiment fondamental de la france et de
la république d'inscrire deux réitéré
jeudi vient de réitérer parce que c'est
déjà ailleurs de réitérer la des
priorités liées aux fins et pas
d'ailleurs les priorités mais le
changement climatique qui ne figure pas
dans la charte la diversité biologique
qui figure déjà dans la sarthe il la
préservation d'un environnement qui
figure déjà dans l'oeuf
on pourrait dire que la france pourrait
se montrer enfin faire figure de modèle
en parce qu'il ya très peu de
constitution dans le monde
qui mentionne explicitement la question
du dérèglement climatique
sur le fond comme sur la forme je suis
favorable s'il devait y avoir une
révision constitutionnelle je suis
évidemment davantage favorable à ce que
l'on modifie l'article premier de la
constitution plutôt que l'article 34
l'article 34 de la constitution il n'y a
pas besoin de le modifier pour affirmer
la compétence du législateur en matière
d'environnement et d'ailleurs il
intervient déjà largement que ce soit
pour lutter contre les changements
climatiques ou pour lutter contre
l'érosion de la biodiversité pour le
second membre de phrase c'est à dire
lutte contre le changement climatique
pour moi il n'y a pas de différence à
faire en termes de portée juridique
entre l'utilisation de l'indicatif
présent et l'utilisation du verbe
garantir pour moi ya pas différence de
portée juridique
j'ai en revanche une réserve sur l'objet
de la lutte
c'est à dire en lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique lutte et ça il
faut s'attaquer aux causes en fait donc
là c'est on lutte contre des
conséquences
donc je me demande si ce n'est pas de ce
côté là qu'il aurait fallu peut-être un
peu plus réfléchir lutter contre les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre par
exemple on s'attaque aux causes mais
lutter contre une conséquence de
certaines actions c'est un peu enfin ça
peut interroger
autre aspect alors qui est important
aussi c'est est il nécessaire de
distinguer la préservation de
l'environnement de celle de la diversité
biologique et de la question du
dérèglement climatique
donc théoriquement et enfin pour moi ça
ne fait aucun doute l'environnement
inclut évidemment la lutte contre les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre le
dérèglement climatique et la
préservation de la biodiversité
ça c'est le point de vue théorique
juridiquement maintenant la diversité
biologique elle est déjà expressément
mentionnée dans la charte de
l'environnement notamment dans le
préambule
donc je ne vois pas vraiment l'intérêt
de le redire si ce n'est symbolique à
l'article 1er est d'ailleurs dans la
définition de législatives en des
composantes de l'environnement parce que
en droit français c'est comme ça qu'on a
défini l'environnement c'est par une
définition de ses différentes
composantes à l'article 110-1 du code de
l'environnement dans les composantes de
l'environnement vous avez expressément
mentionné la diversité biologique
pour moi il est totalement inopportun de
modifier se dit bien de modifier la
scientologie ron il ya quand même enfin
elle a été intégrée finalement sur une
sur les chaînes de la constitution de 58
et des autres textes qui sont dans le
préambule on n'a jamais modifié le
préambule de la constitution de 58 ça
serait quand même créé un précédent
surtout sur le texte le plus récent qui
est été intégré dans le préambule ans
donc ça c'est plutôt des éléments de de
forme mais ça ne me semble pas au
portant par ailleurs ça ne sent pas non
plus utile de préciser la charte de
l'environnement ce qu'ils en fin là
c'est une autre c'est une autre question
pourquoi parce que je considère que les
articles de la charte de l'environnement
sont claires sont clairs ils sont
d'ailleurs beaucoup plus précis que
certains articles du préambule de 46 ans
le droit au repos aux loisirs va je
pourrais citer d'autres exemples mais
pour moi les articles de la charte de
l'environnement sont claires et sur la
question de leur justiciabilité c'est
tout
conseil constitutionnel qu'il revient de
préciser la portée des différents
éléments contenus dans la charte de
l'environnement dont précisé la
justiciabilité et on voit bien que
depuis l'adoption de la charte de
l'environnement et notamment à travers
la qpc le conseil constitutionnel a
précisé l'avocat bilité de la plupart
des dispositions de la charte de
l'environnement article 1 à l'article 4
de la charte
article 7 évidemment seul la question de
l'article 5 sur le principe de
précaution n'a pas encore été
véritablement tranché puisque le conseil
considère plutôt réservé cette question
de l'avocat bilité seul de l'article 5
mais pour moi ce qui est en cause ce
n'est pas la manière dont est écrite la
charte de l'environnement c'est la
manière dont le juge interprète
éventuellement ces dispositions le
préambule de la charte tout le monde
doutait de son avocat bilité du fait
qu'on pouvait éventuellement s'appuyer
sur ses dispositions et on a bien vu que
là encore le conseil constitutionnel
récemment n'a pas hésité à s'appuyer sur
les considérants de la charte de
l'environnement
dans sa décision du 31 janvier 2020 et
pour en déduire un objectif de valeur
constitutionnelle canton principe de
précaution dont la modification
actuel enfin voilà revient souvent dans
les débats plusieurs propositions de
modification de cet article alors pour
moi c'est celui qui est le plus
précisément définies dans la charte de
l'environnement
d'abord c'est le plus long alors ça veut
pas dire que parce que c'est donc c'est
plus clair mais à mon sens il est très
clair l'article 5
on désigne enfin le constituant a
désigné clairement les débiteurs aux
fesses de dire à qui incombe
l'obligation de mettre en oeuvre le
principe de précaution les autorités
publiques
il a pris le soin de préciser que les
autorités publiques veillent à
l'application du principe dans leurs
domaines d'attributions dans leurs
domaines d'attributions ce qui permet
concrètement aux juges à de multiples
reprises il a fait de bien respecter la
répartition de faire respecter la
répartition des compétences entre ce qui
relève de l'état et ce qui relève du
pouvoir de police administrative
générale du maire il l'a fait en matière
d' ogm il l'a fait en matière de
d'antennes relais de téléphonie mobile
de santé parce que finalement c'est
presque dans le domaine de la santé
comme principe de précaution est le plus
appliqué invoqué plus qu'en matière
d'environnement se trouvant donc de ce
point de vue là le débiteur de
l'obligation me semble assez clairement
identifié les conditions de mise en
oeuvre du principe sont également clair
un risque de dommages graves et
irréversibles cumulative de conditions
cumulatives un risque de dommages graves
et irréversibles à l'environnement et
enfin les mesures l'article énonce
également quelles sont les mesures à
mettre en oeuvre en cas de risque de
réalisation d'un dommage grave et
irréversible à l'environnement puisqu'il
s'agit pour les autorités publiques de
prendre des mesures provisoires et
proportionnées donc on a là quand même
deux qualificatifs qui encadre la mise
en oeuvre de l'article 5 mise en oeuvre
de mesures provisoires et proportionnées
afin de parer à la réalisation du
dommage
autre toit alors est ce que c'est le
plus difficile je ne sais pas faut-il
consacré au niveau constitutionnel
un principe de non régression en matière
d'environnement et cas l'analyse
éventuellement faire de la jurisprudence
fin de la dernière jurisprudence du
conseil constitutionnel à laquelle gm
le jeu revient sur le ressort à laquelle
vous avez on n'a pas entendu la fin de
la phrase parce que ça a coupé
oui sur le principe de non régression
vous me demandiez aussi qu'à l'analyse
je faisais de la décision du conseil
constitutionnel de fin 2020 à laquelle
j'ai déjà fait allusion en fait dans mes
propos introductif mais voilà que je
vais explicite le conseil d'état dans
son aile village près du conseil d'état
dans la vie qu'il a rendue sur le projet
de révision de l'article 1 de la
constitution affirme alors j'ai besoin
d'être un peu critique mais je trouve
qu'il affirme un peu rapidement que le
conseil constitutionnel dans cette
décision refuse explicitement de
consacrer un principe de non régression
alors certes ils ne consacrent pas un
principe de non régression mais je
trouve toutefois que cette décision
allait quand même potentiellement
intéressantes sur le terrain de la non
régression et je vais expliquer pourquoi
mais je trouve quand même une avancée
dans cette faut pas toujours être
critique en vins conseil constitutionnel
il faut savoir aussi accueillir les
avancées éventuelles dans sa
jurisprudence
moi je trouve que au moins louvre quand
même des potentialités
le juge rappelle d'abord c'est très
important la liberté du législateur à
laquelle il est très attaché à laquelle
il est très attaché
je sais que dans le rapport qu'on avait
on a eu des discussions avec le conseil
constitutionnel sur le principe il est
très attaché à la liberté du législateur
en ce qui est évidemment normal donc il
rappelle la liberté du législateur de
modifier ou d'abroger des textes
antérieurs
tout en affirmant mais ça ça n'est
absolument pas nouveau tout en affirmant
qu'il ne saurait priver de garantie
légale mais ce qui est nouveau c'est de
l'appliquer à l'environnement et ce lot
fendant qu'il utilise donc tout en
affirmant que le législateur ne saurait
priver de garanties légales le droit de
vivre dans un environnement et et c'est
à dire en d'autres termes le droit de
l'homme à l'environnement
et eux
cette jurisprudence donc elle n'est pas
nouvelle à ses ailes a déjà été
appliquée dans d'autres domaines c'est
son application au domaine de
l'environnement qui est plus novatrices
et donc simplement ils affirment d'une
certaine manière qu'on peut toujours
modifier un régime juridique
même s'il est constitutionnellement
protégés mais c'est la fameuse théorie
va vous ceux de ce qu'on appelle le
contrôle pas les faits artichauts c'est
à dire qu'on peut enlever feuille à
feuille éventuellement des éléments de
ce régime juridique
constitutionnellement protégés mais il
ne faut pas en toucher le coeur c'est
pour ça qu'un auteur célèbre avait parlé
de la jurisprudence de l'effet
artichauts et dans cette décision que
fait le juge
pour moi il opère un contrôle assez
classique somme toute delà de la
proportionnalité de la mesure qui vient
là en l'occurrence limiter le
éventuellement le droit de l'homme à
l'environnement
donc il vérifie qu'elle est justifiée
par un motif d'intérêt général il cale
et proportionnées à l'objectif poursuivi
ce qui est plus intéressant et plus
innovant c'est que le conseil
constitutionnel se fonde sur l'article 2
de la charte relatif au devoir de
préserver et d'améliorer la protection
de l'environnement
et c'est là quand même qu'on peut voir
une ouverture vers une application
implicite du principe de non régression
parce que dans l'article de l'obligation
de ne pas alors je n'aime pas dire de ne
pas régresser parce que c'est pas du
tout ça en fait que l'état de la
protection de l'environnement ne
connaissent pas d'amoindrissement ça
veut pas dire qu'il ne faut pas ça ne
porte pas sur le droit mais sur l'objet
mais je vais y revenir tout d'abord de
manière plus claire c'est en fait il est
contenu dans l'article 2 c'est à dire
c'est la préservation et l'amélioration
de l'environnement vers laquelle il faut
tendre et donc ça c'est intéressant
et de mon point de vue mais vraiment je
sais tu pas l'opinion la plus partagée
en de mon point de vue c'est justement
au regard de cet article 2 de la charte
de l'environnement qu'implicitement le
juge peut déjà contrôler d'éventuels
régression dans les lois adoptées par le
parlement
[Musique]